hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar Automation and optimization
Technologies for bioprocessing
operations
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Fujifilm Irvine scientific
to learn more please visit
irvinescide.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Tom Fletcher director of process
development r d at Fujifilm Urban Irvine
scientific and Guy Matthews director of
Market development single-use technology
at Fujifilm Irvine scientific
some guy you may now begin your
presentation
all right thank you so much for the kind
introduction and it's absolutely my
pleasure today to talk to you on this
topic so when you hear the name Fujifilm
many of you already recognize the name
as a company heavily invested in life
sciences and in particular you know cell
biology is kind of at the center of Life
Sciences for Fujifilm so this has been
an absolute uh you know strong benefit
to our business Fujifilm Irvine
scientific as we support so many
interesting activities with cell culture
media so we're very involved in many uh
areas here and it's been a real boost to
our position in the life science Market
so as a company uh Fujifilm Irvine
scientific has been uh in involved in
cell culture media for over 50 years so
we're actually one of the very first
companies focused on developing and
supplying cell culture media and so
again something that some of you know
but maybe not all of you is we represent
a company that was first in developing
serum free media for Cho serum free
media for hybridoma cells and serum free
media for hek293 cells so that was quite
a few years ago and of course we've been
very busy finding ways to improve media
continuously and keeping up with uh the
needs of the industry so we've been been
in the business a long time been around
the block a few times and so we're happy
to give an update now on the business
and and where we're moving
so we're also happy now that we can
cover the globe with uh manufacturing
and supply and so you know we have
manufacturing facilities on three
continents here in the U.S in Japan and
then in the Netherlands and actually
these slides were made several weeks ago
so I'm I'm happy to be the one to tell
you that we have a new facility being
built in North Carolina which will be
become our largest uh in terms of
capacity and that allows us to supply
both codes of the U.S on short notice
and so again
um you know manufacturing and Supply is
a big part of our business and we're
able to support Global Supply
now when we develop products you know
one thing that distinguishes us from I
think other suppliers is you know we
really take effort to design our
products with um you know beginning with
the end in mind so these are
purpose-built products designed in
several ways to make them uh relevant to
to the customer and so beginning with
the idea of using relevant model cell
lines I I consider this to be the very
most important thing when you develop
media and so we've we've made efforts to
use relevant model cell lines High
producing cell lines so that they're
consuming high amounts of nutrients
we've also been careful to measure the
right things you know we're looking at
growth productivity product quality
attributes
and then when we're developing fed batch
media we we are you know conscious of
the need for complementary designs of
the growth medium and the feed medium so
that they are compatible and actually
there's a Synergy between the growth
media and the feed medium
and then scalability is an issue that is
very important so something else we
think about
and uh today we'll be talking about this
um you know these last bullet points
where we talk about design for easy
preparation and use and so what we've
learned is there can be a lot of issues
time consuming issues variation if the
design of the powder media is not easily
hydrated and so we we design our powders
and liquids to be easy to prepare and
use
um and so we'll talk more about how we
can avoid adjustments such as pH
osmolality Qs in the water volume and
our powders are always designed to be
soluble filterable and stable so how can
we take these advantages that have been
built into our products and offer them
to people who own their own formulas so
many of you in the audience maybe you
own a media formula you're just looking
for somebody to manufacture for you and
so we'd like to offer you know our
services not only to manufacture but
actually to help you understand how to
use that that powder media
so
this is not something you know this was
really not just our idea but it's been
clearly communicated in many ways
including this survey that was done
several years ago where a survey of 24
large biopharma companies you know
clearly revealed that there were needs
in terms of media prep and so you know
kind of to summarize these needs I think
people are not happy with how much time
and effort is spent and then the risks
of variation that can occur
and so this is something that's very
important because a pharmaceutical
company doesn't really want to be
worrying about these you know more
mundane tasks these things that are just
basically dealing with raw material
preparation
and so I think it really begs this
question you know how can these methods
be improved how can we do better as a
supplier in terms of serving our
customers other comments that came
directly from this survey really focused
around the risk of variation the time
that's involved the amount of effort
um you know various difficulties various
things that are awkward and concerning
to the people who need to use the media
so again when we saw this evidence and
we heard it directly from customers we
realized there's an unmet need here and
as a supply partner to these
biopharmaceutical companies we really
want to be part of the solution we're
very much customer centered and so if
our customers need something we're we
want to be the solution to that problem
and so when I talk about media prep
challenges I mean here are some more
descriptions of what we're talking about
so when you when it comes to hydrating
powder media you know these issues can
very much be formula dependent so you
know we're talking about com complex
nutrient mixtures and so from formula to
formula there might be unique issues but
typically they have to do with things
like solubility of the nutrients
potential interactions that can occur
between the nutrients and I give some
examples here like complexation or
speciation of metals
reduction oxidation reactions these
things happen on a fairly regular basis
if you know proper procedures are not
followed and some of these things can
occur slowly so it makes it a little bit
more difficult to detect but some
oxidation reactions in particular can be
you know very slow
happening over days or weeks so being
aware of that chemistry and how to how
to minimize this risk or how to prevent
it I think is very valuable to the end
user and then again because of the
complexity of these formulas and the
chemistry some of these things are
difficult to predict they're not well
characterized and so having been in this
business for over 50 years again we've
seen you know many examples of the thing
the things I've listed here and um we're
happy to share you know what we've
learned from from those examples
so in the last category besides the
chemistry I think this idea of human
intervention you know it's not that we
have anything against humans but I think
that this is commonly the uh conclusion
of Investigations is somewhere along the
line there was a human uh judgment a
human intervention
that resulted in some variation and so
there are many ways that we can address
that as well in terms of you know
pre-weighing
um you know the components or the
powders
make packaging them and ready to use you
know packages
avoiding adjustments you know again I
mentioned it earlier that adjusting pH
adjusting osmolality or even adjusting
the amount of water in the formula these
are things that don't need um
you know human intervention these these
are things in chemically defined media
it should be very very consistent and we
can typically engineer these things into
the dry powder so nobody has to you know
be watching a pH meter and titrating
with uh Bass
and same thing with liquid
supplementation we can often integrate
these things into a single simple
formula or perhaps divide the formula
into parts so these are things we've
learned over over the years
um and dealing with some of these
challenges
now this particular these Solutions I'm
talking about are actually more obvious
in late stages of development the reason
I mention that is we've already had
services for early stage you know
pharmaceutical development in terms of
collaborative media development
collaborative Express media service
where we're simply supplying materials
for media development and process
development so those are those are
services that have been offered for a
number of years they've been very
successful in you know building
relationships as a supply partner with
our customers
and that's when speed is really the most
important thing what we've learned is
that you know later in later stages of
uh drug development
the needs change from speed to things
about you know reliability and overall
cost of this process that's where people
begin to realize wow this labor and this
human intervention and these types of
things that I've built into my
procedures it can be expensive it can be
a source of variation and so for that
reason we've targeted a service now that
we call the msat service towards
improving reliability reducing cost in
later stages of drug development it
could be really at any stage even after
commercial you know manufacturing begins
but it's typically something that's
addresses the needs in later stages of
drug development and so we see our role
as you can tell as a supply partner
we're not just a place where you come to
purchase media out of a catalog or
something like that but this is very
much about you know helping our
customers become successful
and so I talked about efficiency yeah so
our real goal in this service and one of
our goals is to improve efficiency so we
can actually look at a current process
for media preparation or buffer
preparation and we can typically
identify multiple opportunities to
improve that process either by reducing
the amount of time
or eliminating human intervention or
perhaps even introducing some Automation
and so that's a preview we'll be talking
about that later my colleague guy
Matthews will be talking about
automation Solutions and so these are
all ways again to improve the efficiency
of a process we can reduce time we can
reduce cost for both labor and for goods
now when I again I'm going to get a
little bit specific here when it comes
to improving media preparation methods
so this is just kind of a list of things
as examples it's not comprehensive but
we can deliver pre-measured amounts of
dry ingredients or perhaps liquid
supplements ready to use packaging
that's fairly obvious we can simplify
and improve the repeatability of the
medium prep through formula engineering
so we can actually move things around or
compartmentalize components that are not
compatible and that will actually
improve the repeatability so make it you
know simple like you know baking a cake
instead of requiring a lot of
adjustments and things like that we can
design actually the powder formula so it
achieves targeted values for pH
osmolality and again the amount of water
I find it surprising how frequent it is
that people are doing qsyn at Large
Scale so you've got thousands of liters
of media prep or buffer prep and then
procedures require a technician to you
know Qs the volume with water to a
Target well again I think that's asking
for a variation when in reality you can
simply add the same amount of water
every single batch that you make and so
we can engineer that into the
instructions or into the powder formula
itself
we can integrate supplementary nutrients
and this avoids you know that task of
adding separate supplements and again it
takes time it's asking for variation
when you have to measure and add things
separately and just kind of the opposite
we could actually combine or we can
separate incompatible components and
there are many cases where say a redox
pair might cause a reaction with each
other simply keeping them separate from
each other oftentimes can be you know an
attractive solution we can also use
sodium salts of amino acids or other
organic acids and that will help us
achieve the proper pH Target so that's a
fairly obvious one to me using something
like a sodium salts of of an amino acid
we can use dipeptides or phosphorylated
forms to improve solubility and with
iron in particular we can use stable
complexes in order to avoid the
oxidation of iron which again is a
common problem I think people don't
realize uh every every time but um
sometimes this is one of the issues with
variation in cell culture media
and then we can optimize the order of
addition so sometimes it matters you
know you add this before that and then
you wait till this dissolves before you
add the next thing so just trying to
illustrate some examples here of you
know things that we've dealt with in the
past where we can apply you know Lessons
Learned to help our customers
now here's one case study that was quite
um you know quite remarkable in terms of
you know our our customer really didn't
know what to do they had these three
different bulk mixtures and they were
dissolving them one at a time they were
having solubility issues and so as soon
as we got to learn more about what they
were doing we could identify quickly you
know some of the components in these
bulk powders were not the most soluble
forms we could recommend Alternative
forms we could engineer the ph and by
the end we could basically combine these
into a single bulk powder and so overall
in this example we were able to simplify
the process we were able to improve the
efficiency tremendously and more
importantly the reliability of this
process is so much better now because it
doesn't require all of that human
intervention all of those adjustments
all of that mixing time so it was a
great example for us to learn from in
term terms of how much we can help just
based on you know the knowledge and the
experience that's come from these many
years of being in cell culture media so
we manufacture cell culture liquid every
single day starting from bulk powder so
we have you know that wealth of
experience to draw on
now most of these ideas are you know
based on just simple chemistry and you
know on this slide I pick on tyrosine in
particular because it ends up being you
know one of the most common issues that
we that we see and once you understand
the chemistry of tyrosine it becomes
obvious oh well that's why we're having
all these issues you know it's got this
phenolic side ring it's got this um you
know a tripodic structure so basically
it can exist in four different species
depending on the pH so it's very much a
pH dependent nutrient it's very
important for most cell culture
processes so understanding again how to
manage this particular nutrient I think
is the key to finding ways to provide
more user-friendly formats for dry cell
culture media
and then one other thing that's actually
quite interesting and we learned some of
these things by being involved in ambic
so ambik is a great
um you know Organization for us to be
involved in and here's just an example
from ambig where we've seen
um how amino acids are impacted by ionic
strength and so you know cystine is an
example where you know increasing
amounts of sodium chloride can be
beneficial in terms of solubility so
that's like a salting in effect but
tyrosine and leucine are really just the
opposite so again understanding some of
this fundamental chemistries some of the
Matrix effects between these components
is important to being able to prescribe
Solutions and so we're learning by by
staying involved we're Gathering our own
data but also involved in
and consortiums like ambik and I think
it's a real benefit to the industry at
large to to consider these things now
I'm showing only sodium chloride in one
amino acid at a time the fact is we've
got you know something like 60 or 70
different nutrients so it's really not
always as simple as a two-dimensional uh
two-dimensional you know problem that
we're solving in fact here on this slide
I'm showing how amino acids can impact
each other so in example a here I'm
showing how two amino acids can actually
benefit each other it's kind of a
Synergy synergistic effect where they're
improving the solubility each one of the
other and then in example B it's the
opposite and again it's alanine and
leucine here that are somewhat
antagonistic to each other so the more
you have of one the less soluble the
other one is so that same kind of
relationship is summarized in the table
here on the right side where we see that
alanine in particular has a positive
effect on the green ones
going from sisterine at the top where it
has the most effect down to threonine
but the same amino acid alanine actually
has a negative effect on these four
amino acids on the right Lucy nice
leucine baline and Proline so just
knowing these relationships
understanding how they affect each other
is really the foundation of being able
to you know solve some of these problems
that I'm talking about
and so just as a summary I'd like to
just talk about the services that we
offer from Fujifilm or Vine scientific
the express media service I think is our
most popular service and that's where
we're simply providing non-gmp raw
materials to support the media
development activities or the process
development activities at our customers
and so that's a very rapid way to to uh
you know acquire materials that you
might need to do media development the
middle service media development and
optimization is where we collaboratively
help
develop the best medium for your process
and so we can do that either in our lab
or support activities in your lab again
a very popular service a way to benefit
from from our experience and the
knowledge we have and then the last
service is the one I've been talking
about the msat service which is simply
focused on typically later stage
projects where we're really focused on
reducing cost improving reliability and
those types of things so we're excited
you know with this new offering we're
finding a lot of traction and you know
in just a moment guy will give examples
of how far we've gone in terms of
providing even automated Solutions and
so that's actually what I'm talking
about on this slide looking towards the
future what are some things that we
expect to be able to do well again
thanks to ambik we expect to be using in
silico tools much more so uh there are
some algorithms now that have been
developed through ambic which can allow
us to predict some of these interactions
and you know most of them are focused on
thermodynamics able to look at
um interactions and solubilities things
like that on speciation of metals so
these are extremely valuable tools I
think they do represent the future of
media development and media design we're
excited about that we're learning how to
use these things ourselves and then the
second area that we're just as excited
about
is being able to take these
um you know these proven uh
relationships between the nutrients or
this understanding of the physical
chemistry of powder media and apply that
in an automated fashion and so this is a
a new technology that guy will be
telling us about in just a moment where
we're able to uh you know leverage
Automation and uh reduce human
intervention tremendously so it saves
time I mean there's a list of benefits
and I won't steal the Thunder from guy I
think I'll hand it over now a guy if you
want to take it from here
thanks Tom and now I'm going to talk
about a new platform that Fujifilm Urban
scientific have developed and are
preparing to launch in the coming months
that addresses many of the issues you
identified based around the industry
feedback
but to take a step back to the beginning
where did it all begin well it actually
started around a conversation where we'd
been on site doing some media
development work with a customer with
broken for a cup of coffee gone to get a
cup of coffee mid morning
and just as the person was putting their
their pod into the coffee in the machine
they they made a very throwaway remark
about wouldn't it be fantastic if media
hydration could be this simple
and that's really set the
The Chain of Thought in motion to try
and make this process so simple
but what makes media hydration
problematic or challenging at least
some of the issues that Tom spoke about
you know if I look at a protocol for
media hydration it will probably say
something like add the powder slowly
slowly means many things to many people
many different things that different
people means different things the same
person on Monday as it does on a Friday
I'm sure
but really what we're having to do with
with cell culture media in the powdered
form is we we have to weigh it combine
it hydrate it make additions take
samples make adjustments and all of that
takes time is prone to
not not just human error but just
variation between operators such that
you end up with variations in your media
foreign
to do when we we take media is is
dissolve it and you can see the
technical definition of of dissolution
on on the screen there
but there's things we can do to enhance
that mixing there's things we can do to
speed it up but all of these things
again
add variation to a process
which ultimately create variation in the
final product
so if we want to avoid that if we want
to simplify that process make it more
standardized we need a way of doing that
and you can see some of the challenges
that the industry faces on the on the on
the left hand side there items one to
ten now I'm I'm not going to read them
all out and many of them have already
been expressed by Tom in in the previous
part of the presentation but three three
really key ones of time just a simple
amount of time it takes to make some of
these these these media and buffers up
powder containment having that that fine
layer of dust in the facility when when
somebody's been handling powder is is
not a good not a good thing to have
because it the powder itself is a very
rich in nutrients and that promotes
biobird and which allows for
contamination to occur
and then finally consistency consistency
of the product if you can make the same
base material time and time again you've
got a much better chance of making the
same final product time and time again
so how do we do this how do we solve
this this conundrum
well we developed a platform called the
Oco Rover
and that enables us to deliver
a pre-loaded cartridge labeled Item B on
your screen that contains the majority
of the constituents of a cell culture
media feed or buffers
that gets positioned onto the system and
the operator will select their recipe
through the HMI on point a within that
platform we had a single-use manifold
which controls and directs the flow of
water to the right place and then we may
or may not require
um
the supplement cartridge the secondary
hydration cartridge labeled D and that
will if it is required it's because some
of the components that go into that
particular Media or feed don't dissolve
well in a neutral pH and this is one of
the services required to implement this
technology where we decide work with you
to to figure out how we balance that
formulation so the contents in B and the
contents in D work together to give you
your your final product
so how does this work as I've already
mentioned we will deliver a pre-filled
cartridge and you can see that on the
left hand side in specific packaging
that interacts with the machine but as
you look at this you'll see that there's
a cartridge there that's lying in the
horizontal and we need to get it into
the vertical
now given that we could be making as
much as 17 000 liters of media sorry
1700 liters of media not thousand
or 5 000 liters of buffer that cartridge
can weigh quite quite a bit up to maybe
40 or even 50 kilograms 100 pounds or so
so the machine and they enables you to
to lower the the holding bracket down
that interacts with the with the
cartridge and then we Elevate that up
and rotate it into the lock position and
now we've got a cartridge from the
horizontal into the vertical ready to be
added to the machine
so now we've got our cartridge in
position and we're ready to start
manufacturing media
what will happen initially is we will
fill that that cartridge up with water
and that's entering in through the
through the base and you can see the
contrast in the color between the
unhydrated powder and the powder that
starts to go into solution
as that powder comes out of the top of
the cartridge it goes along that Top
Line that you see at the top of the skid
and goes to a sterilizing grade filter
so at the same time as you're hydrating
you're also sterilizing the media
then you will
activate the the secondary hydration
cartridge which contains all the
components that don't dissolve well in a
neutral pH usually these are things like
some of the amino acids that Tom's
already mentioned or possibly things
like iron
we create the appropriate environment
within that chamber to dissolve those
they get directed into the main chamber
and then through the sterilizing grade
filter to produce the media in question
one of the things we do as we we run the
development process to make sure that
the media is going to hydrate correctly
is inspect the media the con the inside
of the media cartridge after a run so
we're looking at there's the coarse
filter at the top of that that cartridge
that protects the sterilizing grade
filter and then looking down at the base
of the cartridge just to make sure
there's no Powder residues nothing like
that that is appearing on that filter to
tell us that things haven't gone into
solution correctly
as we're running this process and on the
skid itself there are a number of
sensors that we're using to Monitor and
control the process which produces for
us a data set
now the data set itself looks like a bit
of an eye test so I apologize for that
but there's some very useful information
that can be gathered from this
the orange line that you can see
starting in the bottom left hand corner
and going to the top right is the total
volume the blue the darker blue line
across the middle is the the water
supply pressure the light blue line that
you see at the beginning is the
conductivity spiking at the beginning is
conductivity and that is measured
throughout the process and gradually
drops down to zero that's a really
useful measure for us because when
conductivity hits zero we know that
everything's into solution
now if I try if I demonstrate what's
actually going on during the process at
the beginning of a process we've got a
cartridge that's loaded onto the skid
and there's no there's no liquid in
there as we add the liquid and we slowly
fill up that cartridge we've yet to
interact with any of the sensors but at
the next step we can see the
conductivity spiked because we're
sending hydrated media down the line
where that sensor sits just before it
hits the sterilizing grade filter
now the next step looks as if we've lost
a little bit of control of our process
but we absolutely haven't this is
purposeful because what we're doing is
creating a pressure drop within within
that chamber the purpose of that is to
break apart any clumps that have formed
within within the the media cartridge
cell culture media as a powder likes to
form into clumps which become difficult
for the water to get into so what we do
and you can see occurring here
represented by these pressure drops is
lower the pressure in that chamber which
just pulls all those clumps apart allows
the water in and allows us to continue
hydrating the media so as we go through
you can see
more and more of the media is going into
solution and that that color of that
media is getting lighter and lighter
until it reaches a point towards the end
of the process where everything's in
solution we've got a nice clear media
cartridge the conductivity is dropped
down to zero we're going to trigger now
the um secondary hydration cartridge
which will see that conductivity Spike
up again but then we'll get to a stage
where we've cleared everything out
everything's in solution we've made
media
and it's been sterilized at the same
time now the interesting thing
all the all the data that's presented
there aside if you look at the elapsed
time of this process it's taken about
one hour 15 one hour 20 to make 500
liters of media
sometimes when we speak to customers
they will tell us it's taking them
anywhere between 6 to 12 hours to do the
equivalent step so one of the things we
spoke about very early on was the
requirement to speed processes up and we
can see with the technology that we've
developed with the Oco Rover platform
we're absolutely achieve that
a little bit easier to interpret just
because there's a little bit less going
on but it also demonstrates the ability
of the system to make buffers is this is
this data set and you can see again that
the orange line which represents the
total volume the light blue line which
shows conductivity and the fact that we
were able to make a thousand liters of a
sodium phosphate buffer and a little
over one hour 40 minutes
now the really interesting thing within
this though is if you follow the
conductivity Trace you see that
somewhere between 30 and 35 minutes it's
actually dropped to zero now that tells
us that everything's in solution
what does that mean that means we can
make concentrated buffers using this
technology as well we don't always have
to make the 1X solution
I'm going to take a bit of a deeper dive
around some of the
um
the consumable elements related to the
system in terms of the media cartridges
and the single-use manifolds that it
used
we have two main
types of cartridge and each cartridge
has two sizes
um we we choose the size based on the on
the batch volume that we want to make so
if you're going to make a larger volume
of a media you'll fill it into the
larger cartridge on the left hand side
but if you're only going to make a
smaller volume you don't want to use
that that larger device then we can just
basically pack that into the smaller
smaller cartridge on the left hand side
you'll see there there's there's a top
and a bottom Inlet as well as an outlet
now the bottom Inlet directs water
through the base of the cartridge
through the powder to complete the
hydration the top Inlet is positioned
just under that coarse filter that we
spoke about earlier and that sweeps the
face of that filter to stop it blocking
because cell culture media that doesn't
go into solution immediately likes to
float and if it floated all the way to
the top and hit that coarse filter it
would potentially block that so we
prevent that from happening by just
having a an inlet at the top there and
at the very top you can see a valve
which is the outlet feeding to the
sterilizing grade filter
similarly we have the secondary
hydration cartridges now these aren't
always required
they usually require for media and feeds
seldomly required for um for buffers but
again they contain the products that
don't go into solution nicely or cause
precipitation if they go into solution
um in the main bulk so and again the
selection of this is just purely based
upon batch size
looking at the single-use manifold this
is purposefully designed for the process
and contains a number of sensors which
allow us to control and monitor the
process but also the design is specific
to the to the system such that we're
minimizing the hold up volume and making
sure that the flow and the direction of
the water is is correct
so looking now at some of the the
implementation the implementation of the
technology probably the first step is is
a media optimization and normally when
you talk about that and certainly when
Tom was talking about out in the context
earlier it's about optimizing your media
for performance in terms of the number
of sales per Mill or the number of grams
per liter of product that you can
produce in this context though what
we're talking about is Media
optimization to implement the Oco Rover
technology so we're taking that
formulation and making sure that the
right components are in the primary
cartridge and the right components are
in the secondary cartridge to optimize
that that hydration process either for
material interactions or just purely for
Speed and convenience
we can also look at assembly design you
may want to change the assembly to
accommodate some sampling regimes
and and that's that's something we can
certainly do but fundamentally the
assembly is what enables the process to
work so we won't be changing the flow
paths and the direction
obviously going into manufacturing you'd
look for support from us as a vendor of
the equipment through the validation
cycle
through the factory acceptance test the
site acceptance tests the installation
and operational qualification and
possibly support around performance
qualification
the ability to provide training is very
important with with any with any
equipment and certainly that's something
that we're able to help with as well as
preventative maintenance to ensure the
machine works optimally for us for as
long as you'd expect it to
but really looking back at that media
optimization service I just want to
emphasize this isn't about getting more
product out of the system it's about
using the experience that exists within
Fujifilm Urban and scientific to
optimize the way the media components
are presented on the skid to ensure
the correct hydration in a in a timely
and efficient way
when we spoke to our when we sorry when
we developed the technology we had a
number of things that we were thinking
about you know how do we simplify the
process
so we do that by having that that
control screen that stores recipes that
enables The Operators to go in select a
recipe and then pretty much walk away
and get the same output time and time
again so we're there we're talking about
the simplified one-touch system and
dependable results but also looking at
the turnaround time and the setup time
how quickly can you go from making a
media to making a buffer to making a
media again
and within that system how do you ensure
that you you control the exposure of the
media that you're making to any
contamination but also control the
contamination of the working environment
where people are are moving things
around and
potentially being exposed to to dust
um within within that system
and the technology with it developed
ensures that we have a contained system
contained from the enclosure point of
view so protecting what's inside the
chamber but also protecting what's
outside of the chamber and then
critically backed up by that support
that we've spoken about on a number of
number of times through the presentation
but really interestingly when we started
talking to some of our customers about
this technology they came up with a a
few more benefits that the system would
bring them that we actually hadn't
thought about you know the reduction of
capex and Opex so capital expenditure
operational expenditure because you're
reducing the amount of equipment you
need you're reducing your validation
costs your your maintenance costs
reducing complexity because instead of
having to handle and develop work with a
range of single-use consumables You're
Now using these this cartridge system
which covers a range of volumes from a
couple of hundred liters up to
um 1700 liters if you're making Media or
5 000 liters if you're making buffer
the enhanced compliance because you're
now making the same product the same way
time and time again you're taking the
human element out of it as as Tom said
with nothing against human beings but if
we can standardize something to produce
the same product time and again that's
that's a benefit
um looking at environmental health and
safety you know manual handling powder
exposure dust Containment all of these
things are really important when you're
doing the same operation time and again
and having systems and processes in
place workflows developed that mitigate
manual handling or eliminate powder
exposure are really really valuable and
important to our our customers and all
of that feeds into this final bit about
operational flexibility being able to
respond to unexpected demands quicker
being able to reduce startup times being
able to use the same infrastructure to
produce more is really important
so I'd like to leave you with that
thought and say thank you very much for
your attention and now is time for our
live q a thank you
for your informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
now let's get started
our first question is for Tom what
techniques can you suggest for improving
hydration of powered cell culture medium
that is difficult to get in solution
okay well that's a great question
because that's sort of the main theme
we've been talking about
um so but it really does depend on the
formula so I guess it's hard to answer
without having a formula to look at but
you know we do know that there are some
common issues and you probably recall on
the slides I was talking a lot about pH
so as it turns out a lot of these
nutrients are pH dependent or the
solubility of the nutrients is is pH
dependent so that might be something we
look at we might actually
compartmentalize some of the nutrients
based on
you know what particular pH is best to
to dissolve them and actually I'm happy
to report that you know you can actually
dissolve something at an extreme pH and
then when you combine it with the others
at a neutral pH you know in many cases
it will remain in solution it's not like
you know you have to keep it at a high
pH in order to keep it dissolved and so
that's that's the nature of a lot of
these issues that we deal with I guess I
also actually mentioned the idea of
ionic strength can be a factor for some
of these components so
just keeping in mind you know what the
particular physical environment is for
the Troublesome nutrient so so you know
I'm kind of talking generally now
because we don't have a formulas you
know a specific formula but once we had
this specific formula we could sit down
and have a look at it and consider you
know what are the factors that are
making this difficult to dissolve maybe
it's maybe it's pH maybe it's ionic
strength maybe it's some other
combination of interactions between the
components you know they're kind of
competing for you know whatever
um you know whatever
you know advantage that they might share
they might be competing for something
that affects their their solubility so
it's kind of a long answer but you know
it really does depend on the formula in
the particular chemistry and you know
we're happy I guess the reason we're
talking here publicly about this is
we're happy to be part of the solution
so you know if you can show me a formula
I'd be happy to have a look at it with
you and talk about what's possible and
maybe it's not possible I'll tell you
that too I'll tell you you know you'd
really have to change that formula if
you wanted to dissolve the way you
expect it to so I'll tell you that
thank you for that
our next question is for guide the media
cartridge looks like looks about 50
liters in size what volumes can you make
with the Oco Rover
thank you um I mean similar to as Tom
started his answer first thing to say
some of this is actually formula
dependent
um so if you know the the amount of
material required to make a liter of a
liquid will determine fire ultimately
how much we can make in the Oco Rover uh
the question is right in that the
cylinder is approximately 50 liters but
using the technology we're able to make
approximately 1700 liters of a cell
culture media and and or about 5 000
liters of any particular buffer and
that's because of the way the system
works rather than adding powder to water
we're adding water to powder which means
we don't need the total volume in the
initial chamber
so because of that as I say we're able
to make those volumes that I spoke about
there
thank you
thank you another question for you if
you said you could make 500 liters in
about one and a half hours how quickly
could you make a thousand liters and
could you do more than one batch per day
yes okay so yes you could make you could
you can definitely do more than one
batch a day
um we've run experiments where we've
done as many as 10 batches in a day
making smaller volumes not in the
thousands of liters measured in the
hundreds of liters
um we've also had days where we've run
process scale volume so again sort of
high hundreds into thousands where we've
run three four five batches in a day
um to make that thousand liter volume
you're probably looking at somewhere
between two hours two hours 15 minutes
maybe two hours twenty something like
that
so it's a little bit you know it's
longer again than the 500 but it's it's
certainly not double it's not double the
time
and ultimately what this comes down to
is water flow we're trying to push water
through the system to hydrate the powder
and if you run a higher flow the time
will be less if you run a lower flow the
time will be more but as a general rule
of thumb what you'll find is it's
definitely quicker than using the the
existing mixer base technology that we
see today
thank you next question here is for Tom
can you contrast the commonly
encountered stability issues for
powdered media compared to liquid media
okay well I don't want to be flippant
but I mean there's a huge difference in
terms of um
you know powder is much more stable than
liquid so generally speaking you know
liquid is where we're concerned about
degradation and that's because you
you're in an environment where these
degradation kinetics can occur and so it
will occur and so we think of things
like glutamine riboflavin things that
may
um May degrade in an aqueous environment
um so that's you know there's a there's
a huge difference between liquid and
powder
um with powder it is important to keep
it dry because that moisture or the
water is what gives opportunity for
things to degrade and interact with each
other
if you have a dry powder it's I'm sure
it's going to be good for two years or
more and so it's got a much longer shelf
life and actually that relates to this
idea of having an automated system with
a cartridge of powder because in a way
what we're talking about is
you know I guess the stability of powder
you have very stable powdering
cartridges
along with the convenience of liquid in
other words you can you can have liquid
on a um very short notice you can have
ready to use Liquid in just uh you know
an hour a couple hours like we just
mentioned so the idea that you can have
ready to use Liquid in such a short time
but still have a stable shelf life like
you do with powder I think is
is a great question I appreciate the
chance to talk about stability because I
think it highlights this new technology
and what's what's become available for
the first time I think
great thank you
so great questions here um back to you
guy with the Oco Rover what do you see
as having the biggest impact overall
sure
um I think it's consistency of the
material produced where the the greatest
games will be generated if you look at a
lot a lot of the ways media is made up
today it's a multi-stage process
involving additions mixing sampling
titrations all sorts of things where the
where the human interacts with the
process where decisions are being made
by by an individual now we've nothing
against people we think people are great
but if you can automate that process you
can eliminate some of that variability
in the product that comes out by
eliminating variability you drive
consistency of the product you drive
consistency of the process and that's
you know one of the major items of
feedback that we get from the trials
that we've run with some of our
customers
um that they love the consistency of the
product the products made the same and
it produces the same results time and
time again
yeah consistency is what it's all about
thank you
thank you another question how is the
programming of this
system sure so the you know initially
um the program the recipe if you will
will be created by the team at Fujifilm
Irvine scientific and that will be
transferred to the customer because the
hydration steps that we go through
whether it's the pulsation steps liquid
entering from the base from the top are
optimized for for that cell particular
cell culture media
as a customer gains more experience more
understanding of the system but now
they'll be able to do that themselves
but initially that will be part of the
service that we provide
great and we have time for just a few
more questions next question here is the
media ready to use what adjustment
adjustment checks are required
so one of the key benefits of this
technology and the interaction with with
our um R D team is that we will balance
the formulation in such a way that the
media you end up with as it comes out of
the machine and is collected either
directly into a bioreactor or into a
whole tank is actually ready to use
there are no pH adjustments required no
osmolarity adjustments required so the
answer to the the question is is none
there's no there's no adjustments
required that material comes out ready
to use
through the Oco Rover
thank you now back to you Tom for the
last question are these improvements
tied to the use of your own proprietary
media formulas or can we ask for help
with the formulas we own
okay ready I'm happy to clarify that
because um just like the msat service or
I'm not sure if you're asking oh sure
Rover msat service but the answer is the
same because
um you know we've we've worked with our
own formulas but most of our work has
been done with customer formulas so it
really is what we're offering is
something in terms of support and help
for formulas that are owned by our
customers so we can work either way
we've obviously want to make sure that
our own formulas serve as great examples
of what what's possible and that's true
we've worked with our own formulas but
um for the most part you know because a
lot of our existing business is largely
focused on supporting custom media
formulas owned by our customers these
offerings that we're talking about the
service and the ocean Rover are designed
to support
processes where the formulas are owned
by the customer so yeah we're we're
definitely ready for that and eager to
help wherever we can
thank you I'm gonna ask just one last
question here do all your manufacturing
sites have the same capabilities
oh okay right yeah I mentioned briefly
at the beginning how we have uh now form
or we have three manufacturing sites and
the fourth one is being built so I'm
happy to say you know it's fairly simple
in terms of them all having similar
equipment similar processes we use the
same milling and blending Technologies
at all the sites
um the one thing that's different when I
think about the differences in Japan
where manufacturing only powder so we're
not doing the liquid Manufacturing in
Japan the same way we do with the other
three sites and then I believe there are
some
um additional capabilities in the new
facility in the Netherlands related to
handling caustics and you know things
like that as well as in North Carolina I
expect we'll be doing a lot more liquid
buffers and things like that so you know
it's kind of a long answer but I think
they're very similar in terms of how
their uh the the Technologies used for
manufactur pressuring but when you get
down to the details there will be some
small differences between between the
facilities and obviously one reason we
have more than one facility is that we
can use
facilities as a backup so we have
business continuity you know this kind
of assurance of Supply it's a very
important principle to our customers and
so we're able to
qualify more than one Supply site for
for any customer who who needs that
yeah we're you know what our strategy is
looking at the the shortening of Supply
chains and the building of redundancy
into our house into our systems and our
processes our capabilities and that
that's really important for us because
the materials we make go into critical
biopharmaceutical products and vaccines
so you know we're aware of that need to
build that redundancy that security of
Supply in
great
Charming guy for your time to time
Junior important research we'd also like
to thank lab roots and our sponsor fuji
Fujifilm Irvine scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to also thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitting during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any one of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time take care everyone goodbye